[Music]
caleb joins us in indianapolis caleb
welcome to the show
hey how are you guys doing what's up man
oh not much um i had kind of a career
question for you guys um i started a new
job about two months ago and that time
i've been fully remote
the day actually not the day but the
week i started the company instituted a
booster requirement okay um but since
we've been fully remote they haven't
really enforced it however today they
basically said a month from today
everyone has to be in the office two
days a week and they are enforcing the
booster um so i'm just kind of at a
crossroads like i i'm not boosted um
trying to figure out
kind of the best way to handle this
especially being so in so new into the
role just kind of the best way to go
about this
so
um man i've had this conversation a lot
over the last
especially the last year
um
here's the simplest way to go about it
do you want to get the booster
and keep your job
or do you feel strongly about not
getting the booster and you're just
gonna need to go find another job
yeah
and
what i've found is any other
angst you give yourself any other rage i
get all that whatever side of this you
follow
but any any additional
weight you bring to the conversation
beyond answering those two questions is
a choice for you you're choosing to be
more miserable don't do that
if you feel really strongly i'm not
doing this
great
go get another job just be in the market
today start applying today you got all
weekend get after it
if you say man i hate this but i'm gonna
go ahead and do it great then go do it
with a smile on your face and going
about your day
anything other than that is a choice to
be miserable you see what i'm saying
yeah yeah i know that that makes sense
it's it's just difficult because it was
like you know this requirement was in
place when i was going through the
process i wouldn't have even accepted
the job and then i was like well maybe i
can make it work for you know as long as
they'll let me and then obviously today
that kind of all blew up so that's right
um
just trying to understand and also
trying to make a clear decision not
obviously a little emotional just you
know those suddenness of it um coming on
today but also understanding i have kind
of a month-long runway to figure out
what i need to do but just kind of want
to get an outside opinion yeah i'm kind
of the best way to how old are you about
it
i'm 26 26 all right so this is this your
first or second third big job
uh this is my second job i actually just
left um in at the end of the year my
first job out of college for this
position okay so um
the vaccine is a it's a lightning rod
okay and you are wise beyond your years
to say i wanna i wanna exhale a little
bit and get some perspective
but here's what i want to tell you
for the rest of your life jobs you take
are gonna you're gonna you're gonna
start a job on monday and you're gonna
get reorged on tuesday i started this
job with no radio experience in an
18-month plan to learn how this thing
works and then kova kicked off and dave
said well congratulations you're on the
radio right we had to figure this out
live and i man i've made a train wreck
of a few things and so
then there's a reorg then there's this
and then hey we're not going to be able
to do retirement funding matching this
year because we're having it's always
going to be a thing
and so and this is with all of your
relationships all of your life there's
always going to be a thing i'm living in
a house and then the
the county raises my taxes
the i live in a country and now they
require whatever the thing is
make the decision you're going to make
and then be at peace with it and go on
about your day don't choose to stew and
spit and be angry and talk about it and
call everybody on facebook about
that's just choosing misery and that
misery has a physical toll on your heart
on your brain on your body don't do it
just say i'm in or i'm out and i'm gonna
go on about it and you're making
grown-up decisions with whatever for
whatever reason great man i'm proud of
you um do you have somebody in your life
that you trust that you can sit on and
talk to
yeah i mean i'm married and we're we're
in a good church too so so
i reach out to
a man that you trust not to say your
wife's gonna be
your wife is is gonna be team caleb
um
or maybe she's gonna be absolutely
opposite team caleb if you're in my
house um but find a man in your church
there's 10 years down the road it's 35
40. and say hey can i take you can i
take you out for coffee here's what i'm
wrestling with i just started this job
here's what i'm thinking through
and let them speak some wisdom into you
and i'm not saying wisdom on what you
should do but it helps take the emotion
out of this thing we can look at this
objectively i do that when i get
emotional about
decisions and i still do right um i get
somebody that i trust to help me walk
through it i make the decision then i'm
on about my day man just because i'm not
going to choose to poison myself
does that make sense yep caleb i'm less
emotional than john definitely hopefully
yeah so i'll walk you through a
different scenario here how much do you
make right now
um with a bonus i'm at 101. wow way to
go man 101 at 26 years old you're
crushing it so
tell me this here's how i look at it if
someone said hey if you get the booster
i'll give you a hundred one thousand
dollars a year
forever i'd be like okay well now it's a
decision to consider but if you say hey
my principles my values tell me no it's
not worth that well then we have to turn
that down and go okay i gotta go find to
work somewhere else that will hopefully
pay me that much or more that will allow
me to still have these values and
beliefs does that make sense
so what's your line of work oh i'm an
accountant okay cool so in accountant
world
you can find another accounting job in
indianapolis right that may have
less you know less strict policies
or you may or here's the thing your
values may say i can't be in
indianapolis anymore
your values may say i can't be in this
community like what you see what i'm
saying so it's where these values go and
they're your values that's the beauty of
them and i'm going to pick them i'm
going to hold them firm and then i'm
going to go about my life right yeah and
yeah if the matrix is
um there's not a lot i wouldn't do for a
hundred one thousand dollars i just try
to take the emotions out of it for a
second and go okay let's look at
logic on paper
versus just the emotions
both are important the other side is
yeah i won't work for a company who
chooses to insert themselves into my
life at this level i don't want that
sort of
um control right great man
and then be at peace with it
yeah and that's what i've been
struggling with it's like if you can't
trust me to make like a medical decision
for myself how can you even trust me to
like do my job correctly and that's i
think that's really like what i've been
wrestling with so hey i'm so excited so
here's what i want to i want to really
caution you against okay i'm glad you
mentioned this
there's a it's an old psychological
principle called the fundamental
attribution error okay
it's when you get inside somebody else's
head
and try to decide for them why they just
did what they did
and then you respond to your perception
of why they did what they just did and
you get mad about it or angry about it
or happy about it whatever so what i'll
tell you is get out of people's heads
whether it's your wife whether it's your
workplace just look at the policy on the
paper
they're asking me to do this this
violates my values i got a month cool
i'm out have a great week
here's a micro version of this um you
walk in from a hard day of accounting
and your wife left her shoes by the door
again and you trip over them and you can
think she just did that to make me
dude
you could get in her head and think that
or
you could say man my wife's probably
really exhausted and something must be
going on i'm going to pick these things
up and i'm going to do the dishes too
right so you get to pick how you respond
here i'd say get out of your company's
head they don't trust me to nope there's
nothing to do with you they made a
policy
just say am i going to follow this
policy or not and then i'm going about
my day one of those choices is filled
with anxiety and one is just freedom
this is life what am i gonna do next
that's right yeah well good luck with
the decision caleb no matter what you
end up with but you're crushing it man
26 100k
not so bad i'll take that